de cuisinier personnel de Vladimir
Poutine à chef de guerre rebelle voici
comment ils gagnent prigogne a rencontré
trahi son maître Vladimir Poutine et
Green passe une partie de sa vingtaine
en prison pour vol et escroquerie dans
les années 90 à 30 ans il se lance dans
le commerce de hot-dog à
Saint-Pétersbourg puis il se retrouve à
la tête d'un restaurant de luxe et c'est
dans cette salle qu'il va croiser et se
lier à un petit employé de la mairie
Vladimir Poutine au fil des années
Prigogine accumule les millions de
dollars et les contrats d'État sulfureux
notamment dans la restauration
industrielle tout en restant très proche
de Poutine en 2014 il se rapproche de
Dimitri woodkin un ancien militaire
néonazi surnommé Wagner et c'est comme
ça que né l'entreprise de mercenaire en
plein conflit dans la région du
don-basse les musiciens sont déployés en
Syrie en Libye en Centrafrique Poutine
reste discret sur cette armée fantôme
prigoging et tapis dans l'ombre mais en
février 2022 l'agression contre
l'Ukraine change tout trigogine tombe le
masque à 61 ans il avoue à ce chef de
Wagner assume sa présence en Ukraine et
vantent une milice superpuissante et ses
accusations contre l'état-major russe
s'enchaînent frigogine l'accuse de ne
pas envoyer à ses munitions il défile
pouvoir et ne semble pas craindre
Poutine qui n'a pourtant jamais eu de
pitié pour ses opposants nouvelle étape
le 24 juin 2023 prix gojin lance une
mutinerie et fonce vers Moscou Poutine
sans le nommer le qualifie de traître
avant de finalement à la surprise
générale négocier une immunité pour
Wagner et l'exil de prix gojin en
Biélorussie
[Musique]